now to a distress message from an
embalmer fishel to his fellow democrats
form our autos our Steve Rattner writing
in the New York Times that three of the
most respected prediction models show
that Trump will win in 2020 ray fare of
Yale built his model combining
incumbency and GDP growth rates Mark
Zandi moody analytics chief
he analyzed 12 models and Donald Luskin
of Trend macro lytx he conducted an
electoral college analysis here now one
of president Trump's pollsters John
McLaughlin John are these horse race
polls that have many Democrats beating
Trump those are all the rage a couple of
weeks ago so why are they wrong and
these models more likely right well
allow those polls that you're talking
about that the media does they're skewed
towards the Democrats they pull adults
they pull registered voters they don't
poll likely voters so there's usually a
few points q in favor of the Democrats
these predictive models are not polls
they're really a models that have what's
going to happen with the economy what's
happening with unemployment what's
happening with inflation the thing is
the Republican presidents who get
reelected whether it was Nixon or
whether or gragan
or george w bush they had two things
going for them strong security and also
prosperity a growing economy this
president's record has a growing economy
and made America stronger I mean you can
see by the way there's polls the media
hide some numbers like CNN had a poll
this month where 56% of their voters
approved of the job the president was
doing on the economy the most voters say
the economy is headed in the right
direction yeah but John all we hear from
a former Republicans never Trump errs
who've made a lot of money by being
never Trump first you hear that well the
demographics are changing and Trump's
base is shrinking because it's just a
bunch of angry disgruntled white people
let's watch I'm still surprised at how
many people are just so mad at
Washington and they don't care and they
plan on voting for no they don't
care what he does a lot of those people
that still say that mm-hmm
they're white mm-hmm it is a shrinking
electorate for Donald J Trump when you
say it like this it's more convincing
John Oh terrible this is the same stuff
they ran at us in 2016 maybe wrong in
2016 fabulously after they hung out with
Trump for years right our strategy was
to bring out voters from the heartland
there were 9 million more voters that
came out and voted in that election in
2016 than did in 2012 and they were
Trump voters and they turned the country
around we won an electoral majority and
what you've got now is a president who's
in position two we had his job approval
this month at 47% Gallup had his job
approval at 47%
I mean he's moving up once he gets over
50% he's in a realm where they can't
beat him and they have 23 deranged
Democrats running off the edge of the
earth where their party prefers
socialism over capitalism and they think
they might have a shot at winning that
if Trump has a solid Republican
conservative base and now he's gaining
among independents and moderates he's
building a coalition that can win and
that's what those models when none of
them were Republican you know figures
but they're those models are showing
that we can win a we can and John okay
we got to go but I think we'll see what
the african-american vote if you can get
that up five points that would be
catastrophic for the Democrats